petite surprise que nous réserve apple
ils viennent de lancer sur leur site web
un nouvel iphone et ce2 on l'attendait
depuis longtemps je n'en parlais depuis
très longtemps cet iphone et ce2 c'est
un smartphone qui avec beaucoup marché
était un tout petit format avec un écran
de 4 pouces et un format qui manquait un
peu et que beaucoup de personnes aimées
et souhaitait voir revenir
et là il arrive avec un iphone et ce2
comme sa sortie directement sur le site
ce que fait donc faire aujourd'hui c'est
eh bien vous le présentez vous expliquer
sa fiche technique voir si c'est
intéressant voir s'il peut être fait
pour vous tout est là dessus j'ai pas eu
le temps de l'apprendre donc ne m'en
voulez pas on va ce projet là dessus
directement on va tout de suite
commencer un point très intéressant
c'est le poids c'est un smartphone qui
fait 148 g
donc vraiment léger un format petit en
fait petit mais un peu plus grand que ce
qu'on avait avec l'iphone et ceux de la
première génération
on va avoir quelques centimètres en plus
parce que l'écran est un petit peu plus
grand mais en terme de design
il ressemble vraiment à l'iphone est ce
on reste vraiment dans l'adn de l'iphone
et ceux qui avait cartonné on a ici un
mélange de matériaux avoir un châssis en
aluminium et un dos en verre dispo en
trois couleurs en noir en blanc mais
également rouge le fameux de product red
qui marche toujours très bien chez apple
ici on n'a pas un écran 4 pouces ont un
écran de 4,7 pouces et une dali psc du
lcd
c'est l'écran retina hd la résolution
c'est 1334 par 750 pixels à 326 pixels
par pouce
en fait ça vient positionner exactement
entre l'iphone et ceux de première
génération et l'iphone 10 r on est
vraiment à mi chemin et si c'est pas du
full hd mais si vous connaissez
l'excellent travail qui a été fait sur
l'iphone 10
r pour moi qu'on n'est pas sur une dalle
full hd est bien un peu sur toujours des
très belles dan très bien calibrée en hd
donc en termes d'expérience ça devrait
bien se passer
bien évidemment tout ça on le verra lors
du test vous invite donc à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà le cas un écran
trou tonnes avec une luminosité maximale
de 625 mythe c'est parce qu'ils sentent
tous qu'avec le plus lumineux
c'est la même luminosité sur les fun 10r
avoir bien évidemment pareil lors du
tech
on va pas avoir ici l'écran le plus
grand on va pas avoir la meilleure
expérience multimédia sait pas non plus
combien chercher par contre apple a
quand même pris soin de mettre des haut
parleurs pour ajouter un peu plus
d'immersion
lorsque vous allez jouer parce que oui
on peut bien jouer également sur l'écran
4,7 pouces en tout cas on le faisait
avant avant même d'avoir des écran
beaucoup plus grand
donc on pourra continuer à le faire là
dessus en terme de performance et ça
aussi c'est très très très bien ils nous
ont mis leurs dernières puces c'est la
même que vous avez dans l'iphone 11
promax c'est la puce attrait
bionic qui fonctionne parfaitement bien
avec de la réalité augmentée qui sera
parfaitement bien pour la gestion de
votre batterie et la vue vous avez un
petit écran de 4,7 pouces normalement
autonomie de rekem est plutôt pas mal
il faut savoir que sur l'iphone est ce
que vous aviez il de puces à neuf donc
vraiment ancienne génération
alors que vous aviez soit 32 soit 128
sans l'iphone est ce ici vous avez 64
128 ou 256 giga de stockage un
smartphone qui se recharge avec un câble
ait ni aux annonces la même autonomie
que sur l'iphone 8
bien évidemment tous avoir également
lors du test vous avez un chercheur de
18 watts qui inclut que par les
travailleurs chargés de 0 à 50 % en 30
minutes et vous pouvez le recharger avec
de la recharge sans fil bien évidemment
il faut acheter le chargeur à part l'eau
sca ios 13 vous avez un seul capteur
photo à l'arrière et c'est une caméra de
12 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.8 de la stabilisation optique vous
aviez aussi une caméra 2 mégapixels
avant mais elle ouvre à f 2.2 si je dis
pas de bêtises vous avez un zoom
numérique voit cinq la camerata 17 une
cette méga pixels qui ouvre à f 2.2
alors que sur l'iphone et ceux de
première génération vous avez une caméra
de 2 mégapixels
donc ça veut quand même changé un peu
l'histoire vous avez la technologie
smart hdr pour vos photos le mode
portrait logiciel grâce à la puce à 13
bionique aussi bien pour votre caméra
arrière que votre caméra de celle fille
avec tous les modes qu'on connaît le
vote eu d'yeux naturel monocle et rastan
et compagnie de la vidéo auquel cas
jusqu'à 60 images par seconde et de
l'enregistrement stéréo
ici pas de faith heidi wood un design un
peu anciens avec touch heidi qui est
préservée permet d'économiser un peu au
niveau du prix nouveau sur ce modèle là
puisqu'on n'avait pas sur cette
génération c'est une certification ip67
on a dû toucher apic vous avez du wifi 6
ça c'est vachement bien et du bluetooth
5.0 vous pouvez mettre une carte
d'indochine et une estime et les pré
commandes vont ouvrir le 17 avril à 14
heures très précises en termes de tarifs
vous avez trois config donc trois tarifs
différents pour la version 64 giga de
stockage vous êtes à 489 euros
c'est à dire que vous avez un iphone 9
avec la dernière puce la a13 bionique
qui marchent merveilleusement bien à
moins de 500 euros alors bien évidemment
c'est un petit écran 4,7 pouces mais
c'est un produit qui s'adresse vraiment
personnes qui veulent des petits formats
des petits iphone extrêmement performant
je pense aussi très endurant tous à
avoir bien évidemment lors des phases de
test en gros si on vient chez ce
smartphone c'est qu'on veut laisser
ancien d'apple on veut la puissance on
veut la performance on veuille os on va
faire quelques photos de temps en temps
mais pas trop on veut pas très grands
vins petit encombrement 20 smartphones
léger qu'il passe partout il vient
vraiment apporté une brique
supplémentaire chez apple autres vous
l'aviez mais sur un ancien modèle qui
était plutôt actuelle donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de réactualiser
et qui trouve vraiment sa place dans la
gamme phase de configuration vous êtes
en 128 giga vont monter à 539 euros et
sur la version 256 giga vous êtes à 659
euros
voilà pour la fiche technique de ce
produit vous ai décrit un peu les usages
on a un iphone qui vous permettra de
vous connecter facilement très
rapidement à la maison avec le wifi 6
très facilement avec mon airpod avec le
bluetooth 5.0 la collectivité est
vraiment réservé dans ma voix haute au
leader est plutôt bonne
la performance est vraiment là vous
n'avez pas lourd en terme de photos des
connaisseurs apple pourrait déjà faire
des choses très bien à mon avis avec
cette caméra de 2 mégapixels
voilà pour ce produit se vend depuis
très longtemps je peux donc pas vous en
parler à vous de venir maintenant vous
ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaires et vous invite bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce qu'on en
parlera très prochainement
on se tester et je vous dirai donc tout
par rapport à cet iphone s2 pour ce nous
embrasse rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer par les tec a demandé aux
cadres
[Musique]